Well, here's one way to do it.
In state 2, I could put another edge for a - z,
and now if there's a new input, like abc1, we would start here, a, b, c, 1, and accept.
However, there's an alternative answer where we add this edge to state 1,
still labeled a - z.
Now if we see the abc1, it's a, b, c, 1.
Both of these approaches work, and you'll just have to decide which one you like more.
This is an instance of creativity.
Typically in computer science, we prefer the green solution
because the red solution is a little ambiguous.
Here in state 1, we have 2 edges going out of state 1, both labeled a - z.
That could get a bit confusing.
By contrast in the green solution--solution going off of state 2,
we don't see as much.
We can either transition here on 0 - 9 or transition on a - z,
but we have to always know just what to do.